when I was writing a script this whole  kind of Hedwig taking Casey out of the  room sequence was much longer and what  you're about to see is a kind of a  little beat of what we were originally  thinking that Hedwig would play all  these weird games and with her and keep  acting like this is the funnest moment  of his life having this girl and he gets  to take her out and he's kind of on a  date and he's doing the best he can he's  only 10 years old  but I we ended in the end again we  wanted to get to that dance moment as  soon as possible and really I was kind  of being redundant you know saying okay  he's he's weird and and having fun and  this is kind of scary and I kept doing  the same beat so it was very redundant  so that's why I took it out but it's  really kind of fun sequence to say I'm  gonna be big one day closer than you  let's play hide and seek  you